you're listening to episode 10
of storycast 21 i'm james secker
july the 23rd marks the 10th anniversary
of the death of amy winehouse just days
before the singer died
she made her last stage appearance
alongside her goddaughter
deon bromfield speaking for the first
time
about the amy she knew this is on stage
with amy winehouse
[Music]
i'm bringing some breaking news now
coming into us from sky
sources the singer amy winehouse has
been found dead
in her north london flat just 27 years
old
last month my name is amy hitchcock i am
the arts and entertainment editor at sky
news
the singer has had well documented
problems with drink and
drugs on the 23rd of july 2011
i was on a weekend shift in the newsroom
at sky news
and my phone rang and it was a music pr
and he tells me that amy winehouse has
died
i had covered celebrity deaths before
but with this one perhaps because i
really liked amy winehouse she was only
a couple of years younger than me and i
loved her music this is one that i was
genuinely shocked
and genuinely upset by and the grammy
goes to
amy winehouse in 2011 amy winehouse was
you know one of the biggest music stars
in the world
she was multi grammy awards winning soul
singer she was sassy
[Music]
she was only a couple of years younger
than me and i loved her music
it was just a wave of emotion and
she lived a very public lifestyle and
the partying and everything was
was so well reported that everyone felt
like they really knew her
reports that she appeared the gig for
her
god daughter at dion bromfield
[Music]
just a few days before she died
she got on stage with her her
goddaughter deon bromfield who was doing
a gig
at the camden roundhouse now this next
song is called
mother said she's like a little sister i
would say the closest thing
amy ever had to having a out a daughter
guest and they had this great moment
together where they were on stage
together so close to the end of amy's
life please put your hands together for
miss abyss
the real challenge with these kind of
covering these breaking stories
is that you're trying to get people who
are friends and is this person really a
friend or did they just meet her a
couple of times
but the one person who perhaps knew her
in a different way to everybody else
was dion bronfield but because she was
so young i never would have chased an
interview with her
obviously 10 years on things have
changed a bit
i'm deon bronfield and oh my god my
daughter's only wine house
i grew up in east london
amy and my mom were just really really
good friends
out of my circle of like 15 close
friends at least
10 of them call me mum i'm very maternal
so she just asked my mum can i can i be
her godmother
she just had a really really close bond
with me from
quite a young age auntie amy
she loved it when i called her amy
winehouse was born
in enfield in 1983 her dad
mitch and her mum janice they split up
when she was quite small so she grew up
just with her mum
i was just to eat sleep and do nothing
baby
and then i and i was cute until at the
age of about
five then i got naughty i grew up with
my son was about nine nights
her grandmother was a singer and i think
she had uncles who were jazz musicians
so she ended up at the silvia young
which is a famous
theatre school and then the british
school i wanted to actually be a role
model waitress
up until the age of like 16. i was like
i'm going to be a roller skating
waitress
and then the music thing kind of
happened and i was like cool all right
do that then
it's really funny because like i i
grew up mostly like on a lot of pop
stuff you know
late or early 2000's that was what i was
loving
but um i had a love for old school
records because my mum just used to
play them all the time on vinyls
and i think that's really why we bonded
musically because she started realizing
that i was
into the 60s smokey robinson and the
temptations when i've been gay
and she said oh you like that stuff i
was like yeah i do take my lips
she was like oh well come here and let
me show you like some other stuff
take moms i'll never use
them she was a soul singer but she was
quite eclectic
rhythm and blues and jazz being compared
to billy holliday
and you know there's not a lot of things
in my life that i'm that confident with
but when it comes to music
you know i just have to push myself i
have to push myself
there's a lot of feeling of kind of
inevitability
and destiny about amy's story it feels
like she was always going to be
this this huge star no matter what
[Music]
so in 2003 amy winehouse just bursts
onto the music scene with this
incredible
album frank which was just a huge hit
with songs like stronger than me that
was just playing on the radio everywhere
[Music]
i was in my early 20s at that point and
it just really hit
and at that time dion was still only
seven or eight years old
when i started understanding that amy
was a singer
and she's doing this professionally and
oh that's amy's song on the radio now
like naturally you you do you do like it
and stuff like that
but i didn't really associate
the amy singer so
amy it was only when i would
be in a car and i would hear amy's song
or something that i'd
you know be like loading my head to it
and stuff like that
[Music]
she just became this super mega global
icon overnight
and then naturally she was doing what
she was doing
musically so i kind of was really
drawing a lot of
musical influence from her
so by now as well as listening to music
together
dion of course is an only child and
under amy's watch
she's becoming a singing talent in her
own right
peter put this up right now right now
she used to always say to me when i was
like 9 10. i'm gonna sign you one day
i didn't even know what that meant i was
just like okay sure
and slowly it just kind of became kind
of like a
guardian angel really in a music way
with amy
in 2005 amy met blakefielder civil
she later said that their whole marriage
was about doing drugs
and if your life is that chaotic with
not just the fame but all of the drugs
and the drinking and all the rest of it
if there is one person in your life and
when you see them you're reminded of
who you used to be that's got to be
really healthy
[Music]
i imagine that that amy felt
that dion was healthy was a smart kid
i knew what was going on but i think as
a kid
i kind of gave her a sense of like
responsibility
i could see she was trying her best to
be the best
she could be around me which she was
so i kind of got like the best of both
worlds where i had that motherly
connection with her
but at the same time i could say things
to her kind of like what a sister would
be that i would definitely
not say to my own mum
[Music]
amy loved to cook so she she cooked like
meatballs a lot of time they weren't the
best
but um it was those little things really
that i
guess she really liked the normality
that i guess i brought
[Music]
in 2006 amy winehouse came back with her
second album
back to black again was incredibly
autobiographical
she was writing from the heart and it
went on to become one of the uk's
biggest selling albums
ever
i remember it so well i was like amy all
i do is
get on the bus and go to school i can't
write about that
she was like yeah you can just write
write anything just draw it down
the thing is the more you write the more
like you're gonna find something that
you like
because if you um you know if you think
you can't write
then you don't right so by the time you
get to 2008 amy winehouse wins
five grammys she's the only british
music artist to
have that much success at the grammys
ever
she's also clearly quite a smart lady
she wants to set up her own record label
so she does that lioness
and she signs deon bromfield to her
label
fast forward to 11 and i just sat in
like an office
trying to think of a signature to sign a
record deal so young i didn't have one
[Music]
lots of teenagers dream of becoming a
big pop star don't they but
not many have a good friend in amy
winehouse
and when she not only signs you to a
label but does the
backing singing on your tracks i mean
it's just
it's what dreams are made of isn't it
i had a first album out when i was 13
and that done
quite well and yeah it kind of really
things took off
so now we fast forward to the afternoon
of july 2011
the night of dion's gig 10 28.
that year early 2011 and ended up
supporting a band
throughout the summer and they were
playing roundhouse and they'd ask me to
support
them of course i'd love to
so playing camden roundhouse is a rite
of passage in so many musicians and fans
um careers so for dion this is a really
big deal
but it was the last desk i still had to
do my schoolwork and
i remember my friends were coming to
watch me perform because they hadn't
really seen me
in my element i think i got out of
school like two hours earlier
so yeah and there was a bit of a chatter
of oh amy's apparently gonna come
and i thought she's not gonna come like
she's not you know in the press there
was not
a lot of nice stuff going on with some
pretty escape that she'd done
a couple months before so by this point
we've had
years of amy being tabloid fodder really
and there were ups and downs in all of
that she was in and out of rehab
amy's previous gig was in serbia and it
was supposed to be the start of this
comeback tour but amy clearly under the
influence was booed off stage
this was just who amy winehouse had
become
at this point
it was great i had like my band and my
dancers
like the biggest london gig i've done
she yeah she she showed up
she was side of stage when i walked on
there's a few people that definitely
believed in the project
but amy was the driving force behind it
she was my biggest supporter
and i think everyone was just like
loving the fact that
she looked amazing now this next song
is called mama and i'd like to bring out
a special guest
i was on stage i could kind of see
someone going like this come off the
side and say something
have i messed up there's something going
wrong so i quickly ran off and she was
like i'm gonna come out
was thinking what are you gonna do and
it's just like but i don't really wanna
sing i just wanna come out and enjoy it
with you and i thought
okay cool please put your hands together
for miss amy
it came out from mama said which was one
of her favorite songs of mine
[Music]
i've never felt so much love
in the room that night and it being
camden
that the problem already loving what we
were doing anyway when i didn't bring
me out it was just like you know it
amplified
to have amy come along and support her
that night just
must have meant the world to her because
you know it's about getting attention
that's the thing you wanted people to
notice your music
i was 15 i just released a second album
two weeks before
so i really was able to kind of
start kind of getting known as dion
bronfield
an artist which was really nice because
that's what everyone wanted and
especially amy she wanted to
put me on but then allow me to kind of
do what i wanted to do
[Music]
amy really wanted to help dion she
obviously really cared about her
and saw a talent in her and wanted to
help nurture that
it was perhaps the epitome of their
relationship really as friends
and as godmother god daughter but mostly
as mates
[Music]
just had a little dance sung a little
bit of the backing vocalist and
then walked off
and i remember even after i finished the
gig and i'd just say like thanks she ran
back on stage and she was like
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the last time i saw her
[Applause]
[Music]
let's cross live now to camden where
superintendent raj coley of the met
is uh to make a statement on the death
of amy winehouse
it was three days later on the 23rd of
july on the saturday when i was
in the newsroom and i got that phone
call that amy had died
police were called by the london
ambulance service to a house in camden
square northwest one
shortly before 1605 hours today i was
doing another gig
in wales one of the
member of my team were in the dressing
room with me and they started um like
just crying
and for some reason i just had this
feeling it made me turn around and say
is it amy and i don't know why
why i even said that and he was just
like yeah and i was like what's happened
she's gone doing ms his family i just
differently
getting dressed to go and do my gig and
they were like you don't need to do this
gig and i was like no no i want to do it
she'd want me to do it
particularly i just didn't register what
he has said
my sympathy extends not just her
immediate family particularly to
thousands and millions of fans across
the world um
i literally saw her three days earlier
and she was so positive she was glowing
everything she was talking about our
next album
it wasn't talking to somebody who felt
like
this is it this is the end
[Music]
i am aware of reports suggesting death
as a result of a suspected drug
overdose there was speculation that the
cause of death
was likely to have something to do with
drug abuse perhaps or alcohol
it turned out that it was alcohol
poisoning that killed her
the attention she craved uh
she simply couldn't deal with and the
fame that she sought
ultimately um made her
more lonely and alienated and more
driven
to drink and drugs
[Music]
i think there's a danger that the media
perpetuates a certain image
and because she was so well documented
in the tabloids
and even since her death has continued
to be with documentaries and everything
it's really interesting to talk to
somebody
who only ever knew her as an ordinary
girl
because the person that they were at
their heart
is often never uncovered or never fully
understood
the real amy winehouse perhaps only
really lives in those
who are closest to her like dion
[Music]
she was a really simple girl it's just
everything around her was amplified
and massive and big
what i experienced and the amy i knew
i'm cool with that do you know what i
mean i don't need to kind of
go on google to see an amy or whatever
[Music]
i say this amy was like made to be
an amazing mom and an amazing wife
and i think i definitely gave her the
[Music]
a positive way the last time i saw her
[Music]
ten years since her death amy winehouse
remains in the top 10 best-selling
female artists of all time
dion bronfield is about to release her
third album and
continues to write what she knows
on stage with amy winehouse was produced
by rob mulhern
and amy hitchcock for more information
on this podcast go to sky news dot com
forward slash storycast
21. next time
we were told was to
leave our mobile phones at home
as obviously mobile phones could be
tracked
one man undertakes a secret mission to
secure peace
in northern ireland and then later
in the day we met up
with the general and his colleagues
you